c'est avec une grande émotion que je
quitte le ministère des solidarités bas
côtés pour mener la campagne des
élections municipales à paris
j'ai remis hier soir ma démission au
premier ministre et au président de
quitter son ministère vont imaginer
c'est un déchirement
pendant plus de deux ans et demi j'ai
l'honneur de conduire les politiques de
santé et les politiques sociales de
notes raté les jeux les souvent dit ce
ministère est celui de la construction
du lien celui qui redonne à chacun sa
place dans la communauté de destin c'est
au sens premier le ministère du soin et
donc du sens j'ai lancé d'acheter si
particulier une bonne 7e de
reconnaissance pour tous ceux qui au
quotidien travaille au service des
malades pour tous ceux qui chaque jour
s'engager auprès des plus fragiles de
nos concitoyens je connais leur
dévouement
je connais l'implication et je voulais
leur dire un mot pour les lire tous
merci du fond du coeur
merci j'ai une confiance absolue
dans la façon dont il a géré ce
ministère je pense pouvoir dire à tous
les français tous les agents de ce
ministère la chance qu'ils ont d'avoir
olivier je suis transformation que nous
allons engager pour suivre la finale
je pense que l'ambition est intacte et
l'iran au plus l'énergie d'olivier à
l'aube services les valeurs que j'ai
porté comme ministre ne me quitte pas à
la bouche d un coup d'état par des
touches c'est la justice sociale c'est
l'attention portée aux plus fragiles
c'est tout ce qui permet de reconstruire
un lien qui parfois semblent mobile
certes il ya les contingences de la vie
politique et les imprévus parfois
indignes d'une campagne mais c'est
aujourd'hui un nouveau départ
tout commence maintenant churchill
disait le succès n'est pas final l'échec
n'est pas fatale c'est le courage de
continuer qui compte
j'ai certainement vécu l'une des plus
belles aventures humaines ma gratitude
team ans mon émotion famille attitude et
l'admiration que j'ai pour vous tous
elle traduit aussi mon espérance pour
l'avenir de paris qui me tient tant à
coeur et je serai
[Applaudissements]